hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Dan cyber
today we're checking out a trailer from
e3 2015 Kingdom Hearts 3 the gameplay
trailer you ready for this
yep okay the tray represents a game
currently in development the fog in a
future Texan Audio cool today have you
heard of the ancient Keyblade war yeah
the Masters favorite story so you know
the lost masters they're the ones who
started the Keyblade war never heard of
it
you can drop the facade okay yes
all this combat looks better
also the game looks amazing goofy ah see
better bigger person on there oh there
they are
damn dude
Wow
I she's like light-hearted fun but
badass yeah alright we've seen this but
I'm totally down Rapunzel
same thing
what do you sis where's that
they've really added a lot more yeah
Wow your throws designed I [ __ ] love
it
kiss me with ah so good
it's d-cups
ma'am what a fun spin alright if I could
tell what's happening any more on how
Spain shall darkness prevail and light
expire the future it's already been
written
who's to say I can't change and maybe
life will prevail
there's more lightning yeah it might be
surprised
okay just like a light of sound
oh my god dope and of course the plot is
concluded that is [ __ ] yeah I like it
because it's it's like you know children
can obviously play this game but it's
like something that clearly adults can
get on board for - you know if you love
Disney which if you don't love Disney
why you know like the great thing about
Kingdom Hearts is that it's something
that is like a light-hearted not like
the gameplays light but the it's like it
feels good there's a childlike spirit
about it so it's very very good versus
bad yeah cuz ever the thing but then
like the plots like with what even well
when most games are like raw and gritty
and violent you know it's like children
can play this game but it's also a good
game you know it's not like just for
kids like it's a genuinely good game you
can see a lot of how Disney infinity has
really affected how like they did the
graphics and everything to it like a
small extent because it certainly feels
like everything looks cartoony but in a
way that matches both like this Final
Fantasy universe that's going to be
there but also this Disney Universe
Rapunzel's tower looked great yeah it
looked amazing and like the environment
it felt so Disney but also so detailed
is as big hero 6 what do we see some of
that in there because it looked like I
saw frozen well frozen is gonna be there
for sure um big hero 6 is a big question
mark like that's the interesting things
like the last official like main
storyline king of hard skinny marks -
Disney had a record acquired both Lucas
films and Marvel so the big question
being is there going to be a Star Wars
world is there gonna be a Marvel oh now
we're talking
what just happened that's awesome dude
with awesome right I want to fight
alongside the Avengers that would be
amazing
are they gonna do it and this is also a
game that is targeted towards a very
specific type of audience it is and at
the same time it's very broad in the
fact that it's like Final Fantasy
audience Disney audience but then
they're kind of combined so it's still
like very folk
stin mm-hmm but also broad enough to
really just like capture a good chunk of
us yeah well that's fair I just feel
like with all the e3 trailers that have
been dropping and then they show Kingdom
Hearts that I feel like people will hate
on the game because this isn't what
we've been getting a lot of sure I mean
like if you've cut if you've come into
the gaming world recently and you're you
come in with like your halos and your
battlefield and Call of Duty and then
you see Kingdom aren't you're gonna be
like oh what is this why can't I go
noscope 360 edge yeah I mean you play
the game and it's just like it's mmm no
it's a blast it's the best it's a blasty
blast anyway guys thanks for saying that
was out if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
check out Dan's gaming channel on this
channel that cyber channel not on this
channel on his channel it's on my
channel it's on his channel
you've also Facebook Instagram Twitter
or vine cuz if we get enough followers
we can get product placement that's
right
like what Tyler worthy what you worthy
of nothing the shoutout
alright it's fair yo r I just wanted s
for a shout-out before I start college
you seem pretty cool like pretty cool
thanks okay some college advice you
ready for this band otally ready alright
if you haven't lost your virginity yet
get that off a list or I lose your
virginity check alright so then you want
to date a chick that you plan on
breaking up with by the time college
ends or at least dinner for like a year
or some [ __ ] you know get accustomed to
it [ __ ] as much as possible you might
have to get an abortion just saying and
the other thing is cheat on her you know
you want a cheat I'm trying to give you
the real college experience here cheat
on the girl also participating
threesomes um you know based off a lot
of porn I'm going to assume there's a
lot of orgies out there and Oh
participated with cocky parties man you
know that's an experience a lot of
people say they can't say they've done
so participate in [ __ ] parties yes be
18 right I guess
yeah don't see some smart [ __ ] who got
like up the you know you know dresser he
got a head ha ed Daou God there it is